[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS KLEBAN: Welcome to GPU
Infrastructure for Compute
Workloads like HPC and ML.
My name's Chris Kleban.
I'm the product
manager of GPUs on GCE.
And I play video games.
Who here in their life
has played a video game
some time now or in the past?
Almost everybody.
Well, thank you.
Thank you because you're
helping innovation.
The question is, why?
Why does playing video
games help with innovation?
Let's talk about that.
According to ML researchers,
the majority of them
say access to compute power is
a major roadblock to success.
Major roadblock to
success of innovation
to doing competitive
things in the industry
is just access to compute.
So as researchers,
as scientists,
as infrastructure
engineers, as businesses,
we need access to compute.
And how does gaming
come into play?
Well, a long, long time ago,
there were no such things GPUs.
Games were played on a CPU.
But then graphics got
better and better.
So companies came
out with hardware
specific to drawing
little triangles
and playing video games to
make them more realistic.
And thanks to all of you
who played video games,
those GPU companies
were successful, right?
Every person in
college will probably
have a GPU in their computer.
Access was everywhere.
And because of that access,
people thought, what can I
do with this hardware?
Well, it turns out it's not just
for drawing triangles, right?
It also is about doing
math and compute.
So NVIDIA, as well
as other hardware
accelerating companies,
said let's take
a portion of this code, a
portion that's all about math,
and offload it to
hardware processing.
Right?
So that's what GPU
compute is about.
Majority of the code
still runs on CPU,
but something that takes
a long, long time, let's
put it all over to a dedicated
hardware accelerator.
Pretty straightforward, but
it's really, really helpful.
And thanks to you
for playing games.
That's made it all happened.
So use cases for GPUs, here
are the common ones, right?
Machine learning, training,
and inference, HPC, right?
HPC has lots of different
types of workloads that fall
into that and visualization.
And all of these are
about getting access
to fast, cheaper compute
to drive innovation.
So let's look at those
use cases a little more.
First, training.
Training on GPUs is all about
the creation of the AI, right?
Maybe it's about data center
cooling or efficiency.
It's about creating that logic.
Maybe it's about
self-driving cars,
but the training is
the aspect of how
do I do something
in an automated way?
And how do I do it so I don't
have to program the logic?
Machine learning
inference is the opposite.
Once you have that
artificial intelligence,
it's doing something with it.
In the Google
Translate application,
for example, it's how
to take one language
and make it into the other.
For production systems,
like self-driving cars,
this has happened continuously.
Right?
Or maybe for reports,
it's a batch workload.
But either way, it's about
doing something with your AI.
HPC-- one of our
customers is Schlumberger.
And what they do is they
have a whole bunch of data,
right, from these sonar systems,
where they put sound down
into the ground, get
data back, and they only
have to calculate where are
these natural resources.
So they do that number
crunching on thousands of GPUs
on Google Cloud.
But not only that, then
they do about visualization,
where they use those GPUs to do
a graphic application to show
engineers in the
energy industry,
right, how to get access
and see that visualization.
And visualization is
really three parts, right?
Remote desktops, that's what
I was just talking about--
HPC workloads, AutoCAD,
doing some sort of real time
view of complex data, right?
Again, gaming in the
cloud on GPU's workload.
And also, movie
rendering, right?
A lot of these software that
run on GPUs for rendering
is supported in the
cloud obviously.
So that's the high level, right?
That's what GPUs are.
That's what GPU computing is.
Those are the workloads
that run on it.
Now the rest of
this talk is going
to be talking about the problems
with GPU compute, right?
Or the challenges or how
to get started, right?
Getting started can be hard.
What hardware are
you going to use?
What software are
How do you scale?
How do you optimize performance?
How do you do DevOps or
manage large clusters
of infrastructure?
And again, going back to
that innovation problem.
how do you solve
the access problem?
How do you yourself get
access, or your organization,
or your college?
So let's look at
GPUs on Google Cloud.
Our customers trust us.
There's a lot of customers
across HPC and ML
workloads using GPUs for their
processing on Google Cloud,
right?
Open AI, a leading AI
research organization,
social media companies,
energy companies,
self-driving car companies,
all using GPU compute, right?
Second, we're really, really
happy to partner with NVIDIA.
Right?
The Google NVIDIA partnership is
really what makes it a success.
They're creating
great accelerators
that our customers
are using for compute.
But not only that, the software
they're working on, right?
The partnerships, or the
software available in the cloud
marketplace, or the
open source integrations
between the two companies.
And for our large
GPU customers, it's
not rare that Google and NVIDIA
both engage with the customer
and help them get started.
So Google Cloud GPUs--
our software stack and
our feature stack's
different than other clouds.
And I'll just give you
a highlight of them.
First, performance, right?
It's all about obviously
adopting a GPU for compute
because you're
trying to get access
to more compute and
better performance.
So we have PCI
passthrough mode, right?
It's bare metal performance
on the virtual machine.
If you're running big
workloads with multiple GPUs,
a v100 GPU has NVLINK, right?
Where the speed
between GPU doesn't
have to go through the
CPU or the PCI bus.
And it's high bandwidth.
Second, a broad
offering of GPUs--
we have five different
models, right?
From the older K80's
to the brand new T4's.
And because we have
five models, you
could pick and choose the right
price, performance, and feature
set for your specific workload.
Also, flexibility-- we have
custom VM shapes, right?
It's not where you're going
to pick the infrastructure set
for your workload that is
just what's available, right?
It's you pick them out of CPU,
memory, what kind of storage,
what type of GPU, how many GPUs.
And because of that, it's
helping you with access.
You don't have to pay for
a bunch of infrastructure
you don't need for your training
inference HPC workload, right?
Only pay for what you need.
Save a bunch of money.
We offer a bunch of things--
how to help you save money
with automatic discounts
or preemptible VMs
that we'll talk about.
We make it really
easy to get started.
Whatever code you have that
you need to run on a GPU,
you can get started in
a matter of seconds.
And if you are
disk I/O bound, we
have local SSD as
an option, where
you could attach it to your
VM or remove it from your VM.
Only pay for it if you
need the fastest IO.
So here are our five
GPUs that we offer.
It's kind of a
hodgepodge slide here.
But what you'll see
is flexibility--
five different GPUs, a bunch
of different performance
characteristics, the ability
to pick any number of GPU
that you want, CPU and memory.
It just talks about
our broad offering.
But it's not just
the hardware, right?
It's about the software work.
NVIDIA's done a great job by,
again, going back in time--
all these GPUs for gaming.
They launched the CUDA
development library.
That CUDA development library
takes all of these GPUs
and makes a common
framework interface.
So no matter what programming
language you're using--
C, or Python, or
whatever-- you're just
going into that CUDA
programming language.
And as new models
of GPUs come out,
you don't have to worry about
changing your code, right?
You're just using CUDA.
But it doesn't stop
at CUDA, right?
There's specific libraries
for based on the kind of math
you want to do, right?
There's machine
learning libraries,
like CUDNN for deep
learning networks,
or CUBAS, or open NCC, right?
These pieces make it
so that you don't have
to worry about low level math.
And you're just using
the software framework
to do your computations.
And then going up a
level, sometimes you
don't want to worry
about CUDA programming.
If you're doing
machine learning,
you might be using PyTorch,
AlexNet, TensorFlow, right?
More user friendly, customer
friendly code, right?
And because NVIDIA has
built this software stack,
there's tons of applications
that are built on top of this.
So no matter where you're
running your application,
whether it be on-prem
or on the cloud,
you're going to feel
comfortable that you'll
be able to run in GPUs
in the cloud hybrid model
wherever you want over time.
But there's a lot here.
There's a lot of
software, right?
To get started, you
have to worry about what
GPU am I going to get?
How do I download this software?
How do I get started?
So Google Cloud offers what
we call the deep learning VM
image.
The deep learning VM image
works for both HPC and ML
and includes all the software
you need to get started.
It has the drivers prepackaged.
We do performance optimizations,
like [? Nickel 2 ?] built in,
so you don't have to
worry about network
or multi-GPU performance
optimizations.
It has a lot of the ML
frameworks pre-installed,
like MXNet or TensorFlow.
It even has Notebook
as a service built in.
So all you got to do is
create a VM, pick this image,
and it has all
that great software
that is in the open source,
as well as provided by NVIDIA.
So let's look a little bit more
about one of our latest two
GPUs, the v100 from NVIDIA.
With eight of these
in a single VM,
you can get up to a petaflop
of performance, right?
This is great for
HPC and ML workloads.
Again, up to 622 gigabytes
memory, 96 vCPUs.
And if you're running
multiple of them,
we have the special end view
link connections between them.
Right?
This is really,
really good if you
want to have larger
ML models, right?
Or if you're trying to get
the time for ML training
to go really down
to innovate faster.
This is typical of
your scale up model.
You want the most
powerful GPU, right?
This is the one to go.
So looking a little bit about
one of our customers, OpenAI,
again, it's funny how
gaming comes into play here.
But OpenAI is using
gaming to innovate in ML.
They do something called
reinforcement learning.
And what that is
they play a bunch
of games over and
over and over again.
And they use a
technique where they're
using Google Cloud,
play thousands of games,
take the results of those games,
put it into an ML training
pipeline, and create better
artificial intelligence.
They use that logic to submit
AI on the DOTA 2 video game,
where they compete against
the world's best players.
And they really
like our platform,
not only for the scale, right?
Hundreds of thousands of
CPUs, thousands of GPUs.
Not just the scale, not just
the price, but our support.
They love coming to us and
talking to us about we're
trying to do this AI thing.
How do we do it?
We're having problems
with performance, right?
How do we resolve
these bottlenecks?
We're really proud that
they picked Google Cloud.
So one of the next GPUs
that we just launched,
the NVIDIA Turing T4.
We just announced this week
that we're GA on the product.
We're the first major
cloud to offer it.
This GPU is really
about scale out
workloads, both ML training, ML
inference, HPC, visualization,
right?
It's only a 75 watt card.
So what that means
is you realize
it's not about scaling
up in the terms of I
have one workload,
I have one VM.
I want a large workload.
I want to be able to
replicate that out
in scale by going horizontal.
It has a bunch of unique
features that we'll dig into.
First is the new types of
technology into the chip,
right?
Compared to Pascal
versus Turing,
they've added two things.
One, the same Tensor
cores that are
in v100 for mixed
precision training, right,
are also in Turing.
But they've gone further, right?
And made it more flexible.
And the second change
in the hardware
is RT cores, which are great
for real time ray tracing
support for visualization.
So great innovation by NVIDIA.
Based on that RT cores
in real time ray tracing,
we've partnered
with NVIDIA to bring
Quadro virtual
workstations to Google
Cloud in the marketplace.
That is, once you tie in your
ML and HPC workload perhaps
and you want a visualization
component, create a VM.
Turn on real time ray tracing
for optimal performance in 3D
rendering and be able
to show your results.
Why is multi-precision helpful
and about access to compute?
So this is an illustration
about the Tensor cores, right?
And since GPU
compute is all about
offloading math, for the
first time ever in a new way,
the T4 GPU offers
the ability to choose
the amount of
performance you want
with choosing the level
of precision you want.
So for HPC workloads, right, you
might want as high a precision
as possible.
But maybe for ML
inference, it turns out
you can lower precision down
into eight or maybe even
into four, right?
And it doesn't change
your model's accuracy
with predictions.
But you get a bunch
more performance.
So for the first time ever
in CUDA, or in TensorFlow,
or in your ML
frameworks, you could
choose which level of
performance you want
and trade off based on accuracy.
So that tradeoff-- it's great.
You get great performance,
great pricing.
Then cost of that, you
could do more innovation
by just doing ML and HPC over
and over again to innovate.
But maybe it's hard to do that.
Maybe your researchers, your
developers, your engineers,
maybe they're
focusing on customer
features over that
optimization performance.
But NVIDIA just announced
something called AMP, Automatic
Mixed Precision, where some
ML frameworks, like MXNet
and TensorFlow, you
don't have to do
that optimization yourself.
Just add two lines
of code, right?
And NVIDIA goes and
automatically optimizes
your model.
So our T4 offering that we
just did a GA announcement
this week, it's available
in eight regions.
Pricing is incredibly
attractive-- $0.95 an hour,
but as low as $0.29 an
hour for preemptible VMs.
So let's look at ML inference a
little bit, and on this T4 GPU.
So why ML inference on the T4?
First, that mixed precision.
Right?
Looking at the performance
of the various generations
of GPUs, you'll see that
the amount of teraflops
per second increases
dramatically
for the next
generation of T4 GPU.
And depending on what level
of performance you're getting,
you're going to pick that
precision that matters.
Second, latency, right?
With CPU inference,
latency is measures
in the Tens of milliseconds.
But low latency is really
important for real time
inference workloads, right?
When your end users using the
application, you want that.
So T4 is purposely
built for this, right?
Let's look at some stats on
end user workloads, right?
Well, no matter
what your model is,
you're going to see
speed-ups, right?
With video inference,
language, image recognition,
5x, 3x speed improvements
over the previous GPUs.
And if you're comparing
for CPUs, it's even more.
So we talked about the
need for low latency.
T4 inference as low
as a millisecond,
for real time latency
and low batches.
We've talked about
the eight regions
where T4's are available.
And the second thing or the
third thing is our network.
So now if you're a
social media company,
or you have a
worldwide group, or you
have users in a certain area,
you really want low latency.
But to get low latency,
it's not just the hardware.
You need global
distribution of sites.
And it's not just that.
You also need a
world class network
that's built to give
Google search, right,
to your mobile phone or to
your browser really quickly.
So altogether, that's a
great ML inference system.
But it's not just the hardware.
It's not just the performance.
It's also about the software.
So TensorRT is this piece
of software from NVIDIA
that optimizes
inference on GPUs.
And some of their
new inference server
software, some really
great innovation as well.
The thing I really
want to call out
here out of all these things--
the concurrent models.
What that means is you
can run multiple models
at the same time and
doing inference, right,
in an aggregated way to really
use memory and processing
power of the GPU.
The way I think of
it is, in essence,
multi-tenancy for inference.
And there's a bunch of other
things that it comes along to.
So I think let's take a look
at a real world example, right?
There is a detailed blog that
we wrote that's posted up
that walks through this.
But what it is, is let's say
you want to run a production ML
inference system, right, on
an NVIDIA GPU doing real time
inference serving.
You might have your users
coming to a cloud load balancer.
That cloud load balancer will
send traffic to multiple zones.
Those zones will have what
we call managed instance
groups that are collections of
servers with infrastructure.
Those managed instance
groups will have one or more
VMs depending on how
much load there is.
We'll do automatic scaling
based on utilization
of the infrastructure.
We'll use T4 GPUs with
a deep learning VM.
So when you create the VM,
you pick deep learning.
You have all the stuff you
need right out the bat.
We'll use object storage to
store our pre-trained model.
When the VM boots up, it
just downloads the model.
And we'll use
Stackdriver, right,
to see the visualization of
how much traffic's coming in,
get the stats on CPU,
memory, and GPU utilization,
and do auto scaling
based on that.
So for all of those
benefits, right,
Snapchat shows T4
for inference, right?
Snapchat makes a lot of money,
and ads are a big part of that.
So they've taken their
monetization algorithm
from CPU.
They've partnered
with Google NVIDIA.
They've optimized how to get
the best performance, as well
as the best cost savings.
And they picked T4.
And it's not just the T4.
It's the fact that we're in
eight regions, Google Cloud's
network, worldwide
great inference.
So that was one example.
So let's look more broadly about
managing GPU infrastructure
and what you might
be able to do.
So it's really choose
your own adventure.
I remember when I
was a kid, I would
read those choose your
own adventure books.
And if you're a
Netflix subscriber,
there's this really cool choose
your own adventure movie.
People love it or hate it.
But with infrastructure
and GPUs,
really, there's a choose
your own adventure game.
There's three kind of
basic models, right?
One, you could say,
I don't want to worry
about the infrastructure.
I'm a developer, and I want to
use developer services or APIs,
right?
It's great in the sense if
you have an application,
and you innovate quickly
with hardware acceleration,
just talk to some API.
Then there's managed services.
This is I do have
data scientists.
I do have HPC researchers
and scientists.
I do want to worry about
my domain expertise.
But I want Google Cloud to
worry about the infrastructure.
And then there's the green side,
the infrastructures as service.
These are VMs or containers.
Just, we're giving you
the infrastructure,
and you might be managing
your own infrastructure
with your own code.
The benefit of this is
maybe there's more cost
from an operations
standpoint about dealing
with that infrastructure.
But you gain things like
portability, control
or performance optimizations.
You could lift and
shift hardware.
You could support open source.
Google Cloud had a lot of
announcements about openness,
hybrid, multi-cloud.
And by being infrastructures of
service, right, you gain those.
And Google Cloud with GPUs, we
have access of all of these.
On the API services, we
have ML services for text
to speech recognition, video
intelligence, translation,
vision.
All of that is
hardware accelerated.
Our managed services, we have
Cloud Machine Learning Engine,
right, Hadoop as a
service, things like that,
and of course,
infrastructure as a service.
So it's just a matter of what
your organization wants to do,
how you want to manage
it, and where you
see your value add as being.
I'm not going to talk
a little bit more
about the API services.
Because if you're a
developer, there's
some other talks for
that here at Next.
But let's talk a
little bit briefly
about the managed services.
First is Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
Right?
It's all about you're
a data scientist.
You're a ML engineer.
You want to create models, and
it's pick your own open source
machine learning framework.
And we'll do training for you.
Think of it as a
bunch of training jobs
with results and performance.
And we help you optimize
and get better and better.
But you don't have to worry
about the infrastructure of VMs
or containers.
Also, we're launching
inference on GPUs as an alpha.
Right?
So you can do batch inference,
right, or real time inference
workloads.
I really, really,
really like AutoML.
This is great.
Right?
Auto MLs-- if you're not
necessarily an organization
that has machine learning
scientist expertise,
but you have a bunch of data,
you have a bunch of developers,
and you want to
create an AI model,
right, without that,
auto ML is for you.
Hadoop and Spark has a
service with GPU powered
infrastructure, right?
Or ZYNC, which is video
rendering a service.
All of it hardware acceleration,
all of it on GPUs, and those
managed services you
don't have to worry
about the infrastructure.
Let's talk a little bit more
about the actual infrastructure
services.
GCE, obviously, right?
We have GPUs, API,
user interface,
as well as G Cloud utility.
We have managed
instance groups, which
are those logical groups that
compute with auto scaling
and GPU statistics for
how busy your GPUs are,
and you can auto
scale based on that.
This is the screenshot of our
user interface just showcasing
the flexibility.
You'll notice here
there's little sliders.
Pick them out.
Pick the CPUs.
Pick the memory.
In the bottom right here,
which is kind of cut off
unfortunately, you get to
pick your own GPU type,
GPU count, complete flexibility
available on containers or VMs.
Let's dive into the managed
interest groups a little bit.
Managed interest
groups are great tools
on our VM infrastructure
for batch workloads
or for real time
production workloads.
So if you're doing training or
an HPC run, really typically,
you'll have a bunch
of infrastructure.
You'll have a job when
you want to run it.
So managed instance groups are
a logical set of infrastructure.
If you're doing
production workloads,
we have things like auto
healing or multi-zone groups
where you could spread your
capacity across multiple zones
of Google Cloud.
We have features
with auto scaling,
where if you want to
scale based on GPU
utilization, the number
of jobs on your cluster,
that will work out.
Or if you don't
want auto scaling,
if you want to instantly
create a group, run a job,
and turn it down,
that works, too.
And it creates that
repeatability process
where you don't have to
worry about a fleet of VMs.
You just think about the group.
We also have features
like auto updating
if you want to roll out a new
version of your HPC library
or ML library.
And it also has
right sizing, where
we'll make recommendations
saying, oh, by the way,
right, we have this
custom VM shapes
with custom CPU in memory.
And we noticed that because
of your GPU offloading,
you're not using
half of your CPUs.
So why don't you just
save a bunch of money?
So managed instance groups are
great for large infrastructure.
If you're not dealing with
VMs, you're in containers.
Kubernetes Engine has first
class integration with GPUs.
You just create a cluster.
You can create a cluster
of some infrastructure
without GPU, some with GPUs.
And then you just go, you
get yourself a container that
has whatever code you
want to use the GPU
and just get running.
NVIDIA has the
NVIDIA Cloud software
that has prepackaged containers,
including HPC and ML workloads.
There's a bunch of
open source ones.
And just bring it up.
Kubernetes Engine has auto
scaling support in GPU stats
again.
So now as an infrastructure
service provider or demo
researcher, you
don't have to worry
about this fleet of capacity.
You just keep running new
jobs and let the cluster
grow and shrink as you need to,
automatically saving you money.
And saving you money is
important because of access
to compute.
The more money you save, the
more research you can do,
the more innovation can happen.
So one of the benefits of
infrastructure as a service
is the portability piece.
So Google has invested a lot
in open source, TensorFlow,
Kubernetes.
And Kubeflow is the combination
of that for ML services.
Kubeflow is the notion of
you could run in Kubernetes.
You can run, in essence, an
ML system and job management
framework tool on
top of Kubernetes.
You can run on on-prem.
You can run it in the cloud.
And you can be multi-cloud.
So let's look at
HPC customer story
on using T4's and Kubernetes.
So Sebastian at
Princeton University--
I definitely recommend
googling his name.
He has some Ted Talks of
the research he's doing.
And he's picked Google
Cloud and the T4 because
of the ability for low cost
compute to do innovative work.
And he's doing brain science.
He's mapping out the
brain in amazing detail.
And it was really fun
to see him pick up
and start up thousands of T4s
built on Kubernetes, again
with that auto scaling and
containerized workload.
Right?
And it's great to see the
innovation just because
of the access for compute.
And it all is thanks to
you for playing video games
in the beginning.
You made this happen.
Thanks.
Large cluster stuff-- so that
HPC workload or Schlumberger's
large cluster of
compute or OpenAIs.
It's not just about a single VM
with some CPU and networking.
It's really about how
the cluster works.
And if you have clusters
on GCP or even hybrid,
you're going to
have bottlenecks.
And those bottlenecks are
going to have to be dealt with.
What's the network performance?
What's the network
latency, right?
How much GPU power you have?
And because of the notion of the
fact that we have these custom
VM shapes and the
five different GPUs,
you really have
unique flexibility
to determine where the
bottleneck is and just switch
and swap things.
If you're GPU constrained,
right, adopt the v100.
If you're network
or CPU constrained,
go with a lower GPU at times
of performance and cost.
And increase the level of CPUs.
Also, networking is
really, really important
with large clusters.
And we're happy to announce that
all VMs, GPU or CPU today now
get 32 gigabits of
network performance.
And we have a
private alpha where
we're giving 100
gigabits of network
performance on larger VM shapes.
This really helps for
both ML and HPC workloads.
So that's a broad overview
of some use cases.
Let's talk a little bit
more about access, right?
On demand access to GPUs, which
means if you are a researcher,
if you have an engineer,
if your organization
wants to get
started, immediately
get going right away per
second billing, right?
You don't have to worry about
long term commits or spending
millions of dollars
on a data center
and worry about if you're
going to use it for a long time
or not.
You don't have to sign a
contract to save money.
If you just have a bunch
of GPU infrastructure,
use it for a while.
Give automatic 30%
discounts, or up to.
And if you're not a GCP Cloud
user today, $300 free credit.
If you're just a person who's
doing your own study, that $300
is great, right?
You could do pick up one GPU,
do some learning on it, do
a college course, right?
Access to this compute power is
going to enable you to succeed.
So we have something
called preemptible GPUs.
This is a win-win.
Google might have
some spare GPUs.
And in exchange for you
using our spare GPUs,
we give you a 70% discount.
And this is really great for
batch workloads or research
workloads where you want to
do a bunch more innovation
on compute with the
same budget, right?
And Stanford University
is an example
of a customer who
really likes this model.
They don't have to worry about
flexible bidding systems.
It's just always a
low cost, low price.
Today, we have two
more announcements
that we're making.
First, CUDs, or Committed
Use Discount for GPUs.
If you do like the model
where you're buying capacity
from one year or
three year, we'll
give you up to a 50% discount.
This really just is a
win-win for a workload
where if you know you have
to use it for a long time.
One thing that is a
challenge with GPUs
is access and having capacity.
Right?
It's a little known fact
that sometimes GPUs are
used for Bitcoin mining, right?
Or large workload.
And because of the spiky
nature of this stuff,
sometimes, right, clouds
have access issues.
And are we able to give
you access to those GPUs?
We want to give everyone
access to everything.
But now we want something
called reservations, where you
don't need to sign a commit.
You can if you want to.
But if you just want to have a--
derisk yourself and make sure
you have access to capacity,
we've now launched
that for GPUs,
as well as other
infrastructure as well.
So I'll give you a couple
of tips as the PM, right?
There's a lot of
large customers,
small customers, medium
customers that are using GPUs.
And I really, really
want to make sure
that you are getting the
fullest extent of what you can.
So first one is all the
different product types,
find the one that
works for you, right?
If you have a production
serving workload
and you know you're
going to scale,
right, use those
committed use discounts.
But if you have a batch
workload and if you're
OK not getting run right away,
use those pre-emptible VMs.
And mix and match those.
And second, make sure you
run in multiple zones.
So if you do that, if
you're only in one zone,
sometimes you might
hit capacity issues.
Maybe there's a stockout.
Maybe you can't get
something, right?
Or maybe we have a
outage in a zone.
But if your software stack is
able to run [? either ?] batch
production workloads in multiple
zones or multiple regions,
you're just going
to save yourself.
You're going to derisk
yourself, and make sure things
aren't causing problems.
So one of the last
things I'll talk about
is Baker Hughes, BHGE.
So they're a great example
of that company who
wants to innovate, wants to
use hardware acceleration
GPUs to do that
innovation, but also
cares a lot about portability.
So they've adopted Kubeflow to
open source machine learning
frameworks or end to end tool
chain system with pipelines,
right?
They're on GCE.
They're setting up
that infrastructure
stack to be a way to
provide innovation
to their end level researchers
and data scientists.
But they love the fact
that it's a no risk.
Right?
At any point of time,
if Google Cloud,
they don't want it for
some reason anymore,
they can move to somewhere else.
Or they have on site
data centers, too,
where they might move
traffic in and out.
And by adopting this
software toolset,
they're really able to do that.
So I'm wrapping
up my talk, right?
To summarize, we
announced the T4 GPUs.
Our fifth GPU's now GA.
It's available in
eight regions, right?
Lots of adoption for HPC,
ML inference, ML training.
That price performance and
the flexibility of precision
really, really is needed.
If you're picking either
the v100 or T4 GPU,
and you're not looking at that
precision type for training
or HPC, right, you're really
just throwing away money.
So please look at that.
We announced reservations for
de-risking access to capacity,
as well as new ways to
save money with CUDs
and up to 100 gigabytes
worth of networking,
right, for HPC and
ML training clusters.
If you want to learn
more, go to our website.
If you're not a GCP customer,
you can get $300 in credit.
And we have a bunch
of technical guides,
like the inference step-by-step
walkthrough or documentation,
right, that you can get
started and go right away.
[MUSIC PLAYING]